Uh, okay.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two.
One nine two.
David P, uh, yesterday on the bonus show I
told a story about catching a dog owner letting
their dog do they're serious business on the
front lawn of my condo.
Uh, it's a small Condo, a contrary to what
the ag man seems to think in this voicemail
that he left, but he is poop shaming.
My, uh, he rather he is shaming me for poop
shaming a dog owner.
Take a listen to this.
Hi Dave.
Welcome back.
Correct.
Thank you.
In Italy, they're not doing so well right
now.
I'm poor.
I have family that lived there and um, no
one that I know anyway.
He's doing great.
But um, hey, what the heck do you want the
guy to do with these dog poop in front of
your condo?
Okay.
First of all, you only inside your condo,
not the outside.
It's common.
Everybody else, right?
So I assume that guy did not see God into
your condo property from somewhere else.
We must live there.
And your community,
yes.
Kicked up the group and you put it in the
garbage.
Would you?
Do you want him to uh, put in his pocket?
He carried around with him.
This guy was a responsible dog owner, but
what it is that you is that you just have
no empathy for people or animals.
Oh,
dog man.
And pick up some food and then you'll feel,
you know what this guy feels he did a good
job.
So don't poop shame him.
You know, like you recruit stained in the
restaurant with you think you do a welcome
back rather parents.
And then Dixon both did really, really good
jobs.
Um, shallow about.
Yeah.
So, um, I mean a lot of what the segment is
saying there is based on things that are not
accurate.
So the best response I think is, uh, listened
to yesterday's bonus show.
There is the poop shaming story.
There is the Italian taxi driver story, people
a buzz and extremely titillated by the stories
I told you yesterday on the bonus show.
Uh, so get access to membership, become a
member rather to get access to the bonus show.
You will hear all of those stories today.
But today's bonus show, we'll talk about the
supreme court decision about Indiana's abortion
law.
We'll talk about a mass stabbing in Japan.
We'll talk about the activist built us Mexico
border wall and much, much more www.joinpacman.com
coupon code.
This is 2020 saves you 40%, but you still
get all of them.
T